[Music]  here's your weekend ticket I have a twin  brother brother baby boo that RunAs  minions are back to their villainous  ways in Despicable Me 3 what is it you  do I'm a driver an expert getaway driver  gets in over his head on a heist he  knows won't end well in baby driver baby  baby baby we don't lie because otherwise  the kids are gonna realize it we will  ferrell and amy poehler star in this  comedy about a couple who start an  underground casino in the house I feel  like a badass [ __ ] see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fan tissa  patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]